what are we making today yes how's that
okay
so
um the first component this is uh from
my second book from let's do dinner and
i love to take like staples or classics
and kind of really which you know i
always talk about how hot you are on
this cover like come on it's like oh so
back to the recipe um so um do you know
what a cluck monsieur is i do it so it's
like a classic french bistro situation
of like a hot sandwich with ham and
gruyere and i wanted to i love taking
traditional like staples and just
tweaking them five percent so i decided
to italianify it even though i'm not
italian but i'm obsessed with all things
that are and i called it the croc
um so should we get started on it okay
so it's basically it's very familiar but
it's just all the elements but just
italianified a little so first thing
we're going to make is a bechamel
which is literally just butter a little
bit of flour
and it makes a nice little thick base
and we just want to kind of incorporate
it so there are no lumps that's why a
whisk is so good and then very slowly
about a quarter of a cup or so at a time
i just add a little bit of milk and then
i just keep on
that's right
it'll thin it out a little and then
it'll thicken up again and then we just
keep on adding a little more and a
little more and then we take it off the
heat and just as you have at home we
already have one that's ready over here
magic of television
so i added a little bit of pepper to
that a little bit of salt
and it should be like nice and thick so
it's going to stick as like a really
wonderful binder to the bread so now
we're going to assemble just some like
really simple sourdough and then we're
going to take a little spoon
and just kind of smear it over the top
okay perfect so
that's fine um so i put a bit of bait
chameleon on both sides and now we're
gonna take okay so typically uh [ __ ]
monsieur is made with um either like ham
some people make it with turkey for like
a croque madame but mortadella is the
fancy italian version of bologna and you
can get it with pistachios you can get
it with olives and there are these
perfect little lumps of fat and some
pepper in there lumps
lumps
oh my god this is the best mortadella
i've ever had in milk i love it and when
it's really nice and thin the going to
render the way you're layering your meat
is really showing so i like it to kind
of like stick out along the edges we
want it to be a little um abundant if
you will no mine's mine yours is perfect
yours is great that is good don't be so
hard on yourself all right okay
okay next up peperoncini
little pickled peppers are like sweet no
these are not banana peppers these are
pepperoccini pepperoncini yeah and then
some toasted pistachios
oh that just gets really nice and
crunchy well you need like a little bit
of a crunch inside the sandwich because
the bread is crunchy but then i also
like to have it on the inside as well i
also am like a crunch nut i'm a texture
freak yeah
i
thi this is this is different and i love
pistachios so much i see this a bit of
uh basil basil
see these are flavors i would never have
thought to put together this is such a
unique sandwich i think about like
pistachios are used in a lot of like
southern italian like sicilian cuisine
pepperoncinis and like
i don't know with pizza
basil is like on literally every single
it's just like stuff that we're all
familiar with not a hawaiian pizza i
love a hawaiian pizza i love it so much
i do but i do think when i go pizza i
want like black olives pepperoncinis
pepperoni
uh bell pepper i like a really classic
italian taste so i love like a triple
pepperoni situation with extra sauce
extra cheese and then i like one with
jalapenos or banana peppers and
pineapple yes and um a bit of ham yeah
it has to be crispy ham i don't like it
when it's like too mushy acid yeah
flaccid no one likes flaccid ham
okay so lemon zest yup
we're there
we're going to get those nice citrus
oils in there okay
so
now we have i want to get the right one
on spank that thing perfect
spank the microplane i'm going to never
thought i'd say that but here we are
there we go great
and then the other part goes on top
perfect
and then a little bit more bechamel on
top because why not does that also um
kind of add to a little bit of that
yummy like burn factor yes
well also the extra cheese that we're
going to put on top is going to add to
that as well that's what i'm looking at
because
the creamy with the polo the provolone
you could use a mozzarella here if you
wanted to if you wanted to go a little
sharper you could just grate a bit of uh
uh parm
or even like pecorino if you want like
extra sharp mm-hmm
perfect and then a couple and then just
a little extra cheese yeah
and then we just like lay it in the
middle
because that effect let me get you in
the oven here thank you
perfect time and temp thank you
oh i'm so bad at this stuff um well it
says 400 so let's go with that and for
about like 10 to 15-ish minutes well
let's see
you get the prettier browner one oh
antony
so i'm gonna go and here's another yes
finger onto each side to keep it
together and i also sometimes do a
little middle yes so that the blade can
rest in it and cut easier also very
helpful for uh cutting ice cream
sandwiches when you don't want the ice
cream to fall out of the sides and
tomatoes and tomatoes what kind of a
knife to use for your tomatoes thank you
did i use like a serrated i use a
serrated
yep it gets that flesh
oh
what'd you say
oh i just said it because i got excited
ah
are we taking a bite we're taking a bite
yes cheers cheers anthony
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like this is comfort food for me the
beige amount really stands out
it does not get lost through the process
the mortadella is really beautiful
especially warm
the pepperoncinis shining through
bringing that acid yeah
it's like a tickle versus like
and just like picture like a really
rainy
day like you know like a rainy night
that we had in new york and you just
wake up and you want something that's
comforting but really easy and make it
your own yes swap some of these
ingredients for other things use some
jelly turkey you can make this
vegetarian
[Music]